study funded by match reveals 83% of
single Americans feel true love is hard
to find and I agree with them joining us
now to help navigate the awkwardness is
Rachel the Aalto chief dating expert at
match Rachel with that kind of title you
must get a lot of text messages
predicament can you help yes there's a
lot of question and answer in my life so
one of the big questions going on right
now I think is how do you deal with a
Thanksgiving table with family members
who want you want to get into your
business and you want them out of it so
you have the ability to set the boundary
and I think that's the thing we think
that we owe people an explanation when
in fact you don't so if someone is
invading what you think is your privacy
or your private life you have the
ability to say hey listen I'm dating
some people I'm enjoying myself
that's it and then spin it to whatever
they want to talk about or the holiday
is a good time to introduce a
significant other to the family both
depends on your family I do think if if
the relationship is new give it a minute
there's really no harm and giving a
vetting period to a new budding
relationship if it's less than a couple
months you know but if it's something
that has long-term potential and you
don't see an end a them absolutely just
prepare both sides for each other
according to the latest census data
people are staying single longer I think
I know why that I'm gonna let you know
the expert tell us why is that so I
think that people are becoming pickier I
think that marriage is important to many
but also really real relationships
healthy relationships are becoming very
important and I think that especially
the younger generations we've seen in
the match study that the Millennials and
the Jen's ears are actually becoming
more thoughtful with who they're dating
and thoughtful in what sense paying more
attention to what's inside so it's not
just looking at pictures it's really
paying attention to finding deeper
connections and someone that they're
more compatible with so I think that
makes a difference and and I'd like to
see that translate and lower divorce so
if you ever heard of this phrase cuffing
season so someone who doesn't usually
want to be tied down the months get a
little bit colder the holidays come up
they're willing to be cuffed for a
little while into a serious relationship
or at least one that looks like one
because it can get lonely in Allah de
Winter squeeze yes yes
is that a good strategy for avoiding the
loneliness over the winter months I mean
as long as there's full disclosure
you're coming with someone and be like
oh I see forever with you and then two
months later you're no different season
I don't know what you were thinking so I
think it's full disclosure absolutely
enjoy yourself but I think most people
are looking for love we've found that
that 60% of people are actually looking
for love it's only 60 percent well I
mean 40 percent of people are having a
good time okay
have a holiday hotline now match has a
holiday hotline what is that about so
it's all about really giving people an
ear and it's we have experts we have
experts standing by ready to answer any
of the questions that you have whether
you're in a relationship you're not you
don't have to be a member it's like the
Butterball turkey hotline the most
popular question is it's honestly it's
everything that we were just talking
about what I do about my family member
that's gonna be too nosy what do I do
with this significant other what do i
buy them yeah Rachel dealto thank you so
much